look at it i'm sorry i haven't been
reading the this is my cancel
pearl account i'm excited you're doing
it you're canceled pearl okay i've been
promoting them
like honestly i've been trying to get
them more followers i'm really excited
you have to be important to be cancelled
so like luckily like i'm i'm almost
important now
that i have a cancel account now so this
is what we're doing today so today
i'm gonna be admitting things i did in
high school to my mom
for her to like raise your sister gone
to bed i don't she's 16. i know i can
give her
tips i know i can give her tips no
she's far sweeter than hmm
that's true you thought about me too
happy birthday to the fan i don't know
whose birthday i was but happy birthday
um okay so in high school when i threw
parties
parties yeah so let's let's
let's bring out let's talk about the
parties you already knew you already
knew about some of them
so it was basically like four days
straight
oh yeah that i knew yeah you denied it
and then you got busted out by mrs
michelski um
mom i love you i love you yeah so what
happened to the bathtub was that kayla
and my friend olivia decided to get
naked during the party and take a bath
in it
and that's how they broke it was because
they didn't know that the bathtub was
broken
so that's what happened during the party
on top of that there was this random
girl named alex from my high school who
came to the party
and she puked in
the guest bedroom over there that was
that was what that stain was
now look mom it's not a proud moment
but i'm a little proud of it so not not
the fact
but there wasn't a lot of people that
came there wasn't there was a lot of
alcohol
because dad collected the garbage yeah
no
no that was someone else do you remember
okay because what happened
was we threw four days of parties and we
were meticulous we cleaned the entire
house
and i told anthony partaker i told him i
said i'm going to wisconsin to meet my
family we're done with the party
and the parties maybe like 20 people and
so i thought i was done
because this is what happened then they
came back
and said like you said there was beer
and i was like beer we didn't drink beer
we're taking shots in this [ __ ]
so like you think i'm gonna drink a beer
i'm trying to get to the point
so yeah so what happened
was i yeah like oh there's a lot of
puking i'm not gonna lie
but there weren't a ton of people it was
just there's a lot of people
so you could say i was a responsible kid
but it was you kind of your own fault
you left me home for like two months so
it's the only time i did anything
you weren't home for two months total
between the two summers
because of sports it might be one year
on top of that um oh he's coming in the
front door
i told him he could just come in yeah
well it's like a slipper it's like a
skating rink out there he's probably
coming in with a broken bank he's got it
i'm
impressed enough now
one day did you get injured coming to
the door or what
[Music]
all right yeah so um another thing
um that i did in high school um
there were multiple times where we left
the house at like two in the morning
because we thought it would be like you
you were asleep and you you were always
so proud you were like you can never
sneak out with any of us
any of us noticing but that's not true
that's not true
then we'd go like tp different people
perfect
yeah so like then we like but the thing
is we buy condoms and throw them at the
front of their lawns
i don't know why we just thought it
would be funny
i don't know why yeah so that's that's
really all we're going to admit to
tonight and whose
lawns did you do please tell me it was
nobody we knew well okay you know what
we did
the quarterback right yeah that one i
know yeah okay
um i'm a hussy
oh i t feed her i t tv the [ __ ] out of
her house
and oh my god she let me tell you
she yeah did she know it was you no no i
told her like a year later okay
she wasn't mad anymore um
and then um i also
i'm trying to think of who else we tp
there is
there's a couple like people that came
in i'm not gonna lie
uh but yeah and you you remember you
were always so proud you're like you
could never sneak out of this house
but i was like mom we do it like every
weekend i don't really understand
oh and then the zero gravity you know we
used to go there
uh oh yeah that was fifty and then you
like ran into the au pair or something
there right here no no one ever ended up
here
something happened or something like
that yeah
and then on top of that we like yeah
zero gravity actually there's a couple
stories coming back
should we keep going or do you think
you've had enough for tonight yeah i
think i've got
okay we'll do a round two we'll do a
round two next week
okay um but i think this
i think this has been great honestly for
i feel like grey this is a weight off of
my shoulders